[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à cette rencontre de
l'Association des Journalistes
parlementaires avec comme première
invité de la session parlementaire la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale Yaël
brune Pivet bonjour madame la Présidente
bonjour quelques mots pour vous indiquer
que nous sommes ensemble jusqu'à midi
que cette conférence de presse est
retransmise sur LCP et sur le portail
vidéo Internet de l'Assemblée nationale
alors deux questions pour lancer la
discussion avant de faire circuler le
micro dans la salle je vous pose la
première et Chantal Didier vous posera
la deuxième cette semaine la session
parlementaire s'est ouverte sous les
feux de l'actualité comme rarement alors
c'est évidemment en grande partie le
résultat de la configuration de
l'Assemblée nationale élue par les
Français en juin dernier est-ce que vous
diriez que cette composition de
l'Assemblée nationale et le fait que les
médias est donc peut-être que les
Français s'intéressent davantage au
travail des députés est à la fois une
chance pour le débat démocratique et une
responsabilité pour les élus que vous
êtes
effectivement c'est je partage c'est une
chance et une responsabilité une chance
parce que l'Assemblée nationale et je
l'ai souvent dit n'a jamais à mon sens
aussi bien représenté les Français et
c'est ce qu'ils disent dans la dernière
étude faite par la Fondation Jean Jaurès
sur les fractures françaises on peut
voir qu'il y a un changement de regard
des Français sur l'Assemblée nationale
donc une meilleure représentativité
toutes les partis politiques aujourd'hui
sont représentées dans des proportions
conséquentes donc je pense que cet
assemblée à l'image des Français et
forcément plus en lien et davantage en
lien avec eux et puis une assemblée dans
laquelle personne n'a la majorité
absolue est une assemblée qui par
construction va plus débattre va avoir
des débats qui peuvent
aller dans un sens ou dans un autre dont
on ne connaît pas nécessairement l'issue
et je crois que pour cela aussi
intéresse davantage les Français donc si
vous rajoutez à cela
une absence de cession extraordinaire
qui a fait que les parlementaires ont
beaucoup travaillé en amont en
commission en lien avec le gouvernement
pour préparer cette session je pense que
c'est un élément aussi important et puis
des débats importants sur l'Ukraine sur
l'assurance chômage bientôt le budget
donc des sujets qui intéressent les
Français donc tout cela
conduit à faire qu'effectivement ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée nationale et en
tout cas aux yeux de nos compatriotes
semblent plus intéressants et plus plus
en lien avec ce qu'ils sont et ce qu'ils
pensent
oui madame résidente dans ce contexte de
nouvelles
d'absence de majorité absolue comment
concevez-vous votre rôle entre les
demandes de l'exécutif qui veut souvent
aller vite et justement
des groupes parlementaires qui eux
veulent du débat donc du temps que vous
êtes coincé ou vous arbitrer
je suis pas coincée
non parce que le rôle de toute d'une
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale ou
d'un président de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est il est multiple mais il est en
premier lieu de s'assurer que son
institution et que l'institution qu'il
préside fonctionne et qu'elle fonctionne
au service des Français moi j'ai
toujours prôné beaucoup de dialogues et
c'était la façon dont je présidais la
commission des lois en réalisant des
bureaux
mensuels et où je prenais l'avis de
l'ensemble des groupes politiques
présents dans cette commission pour
construire les décisions relatives à la
Commission et bien je fais la même chose
à l'Assemblée en tant que Présidente je
fais des réunions de bureau mensuels
également je consulte beaucoup les
groupes politiques ce qui fait que en
conférence des présidents l'endroit où
l'on organise notre vie collective et en
bureau nos décisions se prennent
quasi systématiquement à l'unanimité
parce que l'institution passe avant pour
à mes yeux mais je crois aussi au nom
aux yeux des autres groupes politiques
nous avons et séances là où je reprends
votre question sur la chance et la
responsabilité nous avons la
responsabilité de faire en sorte que
l'Assemblée nationale remplisse
pleinement son rôle et pour qu'elle le
remplissent et bien il faut que l'on
discute il faut que l'on dialogue il
faut que l'on que ce que l'on se
conserve pour décider ensemble dans
l'intérêt général c'est pour ça que nous
avons été élus et c'est là où nous avons
une responsabilité partagée et je crois
qu'elle est assumée par chacun dans
cette assemblée
je vois déjà quelques mains se lever
dans la salle présentez-vous bien à
chaque fois votre nom et votre média
pour la première question à ne Pascal
Reboul de la FP oui bonjour
à partir de lundi démarre une semaine à
haute intensité avec l'examen du budget
le gouvernement a déjà prêt à dégainer
le 49-3 vous avez dit que c'est pas un
gros mot c'est un article de la
Constitution est-ce que néanmoins faut
pas laisser le temps du débat selon vous
quand faut-il
user de cet article effectivement j'ai
indiqué que le 49-3 n'était pas un gros
mot pas plus que d'autres mots qui sont
contenus dans notre Constitution ce sont
des outils qui participent à l'équilibre
de nos pouvoirs et qui participent au
bon fonctionnement de notre démocratie
et de nos institutions
la discussion budgétaire elle s'est
finalement elle ne se déroule pas que
dans l'hémicycle le ministre en charge
des comptes publics à au de septembre
réalisé ce que l'on a appelé les
dialogues de Bercy et donc il a pu
échanger sur le budget à l'occasion de
nombreuses réunions avec l'ensemble des
groupes politiques la commission des
finances s'est saisie depuis hier du
pied avant-hier du texte et
dialogue également examinent les
amendements débat et donc travail sur le
budget il y aura la troisième séquence
de dialogue qui est l'hémicycle avec le
débat et le vote des amendements donc on
ne peut pas dire ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que le débat ne commence pas la
semaine prochaine sur le budget il a
commencé en septembre avec ses
discussions il se poursuit aujourd'hui
en commission et il se terminera dans
l'hémicycle après nous verrons comment
se déroule le débat et le gouvernement
s'il décide
je dis bien s'il décide d'utiliser 49 43
verra quand il laissera quand deviendra
le moment moi je suis convaincue qu'il
faut que la discussion ait lieu dans
l'hémicycle que nous débattions que nous
avions dans l'examen du texte que nous
essayons finalement de parvenir à éviter
le 49-3 si nous voyons et c'est le
gouvernement et c'est lui le seul juge
pour cela constate que le débat n'est
pas possible constate que il n'y a
finalement pas que la voix du dialogue
n'existe pas il faudra à un moment donné
qu'il en tire les conséquences dans
toujours dans ce sens d'intérêt général
nous ne pouvons pas
nous passer de budget nous ne pouvons
pas échouer à faire voter le budget de
la France à l'Assemblée nationale cet
automne donc mais je suis et je resterai
une partisane du débat et du dialogue
bonjour Anita Auxerre pour Atlantico
est-ce que je reviens à la question
institutionnelle vous dites que
l'assemblée est représentative de
l'ensemble des Français est-ce que cette
représentativité malgré elle finalement
exonère d'une modification éventuelle du
mode de scrutin et l'adoption d'une de
la proportionnelle
non je ne crois pas je pense que la
question institutionnelle reste au cœur
de nos préoccupations mais au cœur des
préoccupations des Français qu'il faut
l'envisager dans sa globalité donc il y
a les questions de représentation mais
il y en a d'autres qui se posent
notamment la question de la
participation citoyenne notamment les
questions de l'indépendance de la
justice notamment les questions
relatives à une éventuelle nouvelle
phase de décentralisation et la question
des territoires il y a beaucoup de
questions institutionnelles qui se
posent moi je crois qu'il faut les
traiter d'une façon globale c'est le
souhait du président de la République
qu'il avait exprimé lors de la campagne
présidentielle en souhaitant installer
une commission transpartisane sur les
institutions donc à laquelle l'Assemblée
nationale participera volontiers et nous
lancerons probablement des travaux de
notre côté sur ces sujets dans les
semaines qui viennent donc la question
institutionnelle pour moi
reste central et dans cette question
institutionnelle il y a évidemment la
question du mode de scrutin moi je suis
convaincue qu'il nous faut avoir un mode
de scrutin qui nous permette d'avoir
cette représentation la plus exacte des
forces politiques qui sont dans notre
pays elle est arrivée là avec un scrutin
majoritaire mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'un scrutin avec au moins une dose de
proportionnelle permettrait d'assurer
cela et donc je suis favorable à
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle plus ou moins importante
il faudra en discuter pour l'élection
des parlementaires mais je suis
convaincue qu'il faut examiner cela
globalement parce que vous savez les les
pouvoirs
et notre Constitution est un trésor
d'équilibre donc il faut les préserver
ce trésor d'équilibre en regardant les
choses globalement et non pas petit bout
par petit bout de scrutin n'est pas
constitutionnel oui mais quand je dis la
Constitution alors je me suis mal
exprimé nos institutions et nos
institutions sont un trésor d'équilibre
et nos institutions sont composées
effectivement de loi ordinaires de loi
organique et de loi constitutionnelle
mais elle forme un tout elle forme un
tout et le mode de scrutin des députés
évidemment fait partie de ce tout là
bonjour Annabelle Roger pour l'hémicycle
lors du retour des questions au
Gouvernement mardi la deuxième question
a été posée à propos des violences
conjugales des violences faites aux
femmes elle a donné lieu à un grand
moment de tension d'un victime vous avez
dû intervenir est-ce que vous pensez que
ce type de scène au sein de l'hémicycle
est utile dans la lutte contre la
violence faite aux femmes
je crois que
le quand l'hémicycle est trop agité ça
n'est jamais utile
quel que soit le moment quelle que soit
le sujet et on voit toujours dans
l'étude les fractures françaises ou dans
d'autres études que les Français goûtent
peu finalement
cette agitation dans l'hémicycle et donc
il est de notre responsabilité moi je
l'avais rappelé en conférence des
présidents le matin même le matin même
c'est peut-être la raison pour laquelle
j'ai souhaité ne pas laisser passer
cette agitation parce que le matin même
j'avais appelé tous les présidents de
groupe à
ramener le calme dans l'hémicycle et
justement dire que ce que ce qui avait
pu exister au mois de juillet et ce qui
s'expliquait par la fraîcheur de
l'élection devait cesser et que nous
devions revenir avec à des débats plus
apaisés et plus respectueux et c'est la
raison pour laquelle effectivement j'ai
souhaité ne pas laisser passer en début
de question au gouvernement cette
agitation Renaissance
plus plus sur le concernant le sujet des
violences faites aux femmes
moi je trouve que
ce qui est déplorable
c'est que c'était un sujet et plus qu'un
sujet et c'était une cause sur laquelle
pendant le précédent quinquennat nous
nous étions tous retrouvés nous avions
voté un certain nombre de textes sur les
violences sexistes avions voté un
certain nombre de textes de protection
sur les bracelets anti rapprochement sur
l'autorité parentale nous avons nous
avions mis en place beaucoup de choses
qui permettent de mieux protéger les
femmes et à chaque fois ces textes
avaient été voté à l'unanimité ou à une
quasi unanimité parce que c'est une
cause qui doit nous rassembler et qui
nous a rassemblé et donc moi je ne je
trouve que c'est dommage de se diviser
sur cette cause qui mérite mieux que
cela et qui mérite plutôt que nous que
nous ayons un combat commun et que nous
émettions tous toute notre énergie
pour mémoire vous avez dit que vous
n'aviez pas voulu laisser passer
l'agitation dans l'hémicycle vous allez
prononcer un rappel à l'ordre avec
inscription au procès-verbal à
l'encontre de Daniel le Bono est-ce que
Daniel obono député à l'IFI sera entendu
par le Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale
comme le règlement le lui permet dans ce
genre de cas là tout à fait là nous
avons eu une réunion de bureau hier elle
a souhaité donc elle sera entendue à la
prochaine réunion de bureau qui a lieu
donc dans un mois le 9 novembre réunion
de bureau tous les mois
oui bonjour Jean-Michel Lamy nouvelle
économiste vous venez de le parler de
changement de regard sur l'Assemblée
nationale quelles conséquences sur le
fonctionnement du bicarramide
quels sont vos échanges avec Gérard
Larcher le président du Sénat sida et
quel est votre analyse du fonctionnement
compte tenu du nouveau rapport de force
politique des commissions mixtes
paritaires ou le Sénat à son mot à dire
cher Monsieur le Sénat a toujours eu son
mot à dire dans les commissions mixtes
paritaires j'en ai présidé ou
vice-présidée plus de 70 pendant la
précédente mandature puisque comme vous
le savez les commissions des lois sont
extrêmement
sollicitées en matière législative et
sur les quasi 70 commissions mixte
paritaire que j'ai réalisé donc avec mes
homologues du Sénat nous avions à peu
près 75% de commission mixte paritaire
favorable conclusive donc moi je crois
profondément mais profondément au
dialogue à l'Assemblée nationale mais au
dialogue avec nos collègues sénateurs je
considère que nos regards
qui sont des regards nécessairement
différents de par notre mode d'élection
de par nos parcours de par notre couleur
politique
font que les textes sont enrichis sont
mieux travaillés et donc moi je suis une
fervente partisane de la navette
parlementaire du Bic amerisme et de ce
travail constructif avec avec le Sénat
concernant mes rapports avec mon
homologue ils sont ils sont excellents
nous nous voyons régulièrement et nous
avons le souhait tous les deux de faire
en sorte que nos le Parlement que le
Parlement fonctionne au mieux au service
des Français et nous serons tous les
deux de fervent défenseurs du Parlement
de nos institutions de nos équilibres
institutionnels nous croyons que que
nous avons
la main dans la main quelque chose à
apporter sur ce plan là à notre pays
bonjour Perrine Vasse pour BFM TV j'ai
deux questions je vais reprendre la
question de ma conso sur le rappel
allant de Daniel obondo j'avais trouvé
que ce rappel alors était sorti
peut-être un peu tôt et donc j'ai
l'explication vous l'avez dit vous aviez
rappelé alors les présidents avant mais
en fait quand on regarde la séquence
dans toute sa grandeur la prise de
parole d'Aurore berger était aussi une
provocation qui allait forcément et elle
le savait et peut-être vous entraîner du
chahut donc est-ce que cela aussi il ne
faudrait pas l'éviter pour
instrumentaliser une communication d'une
de part et d'autre et j'ai une autre
question sur le ministre de la Justice
on a vu dans ces questions gouvernement
mardi qu'il y avait énormément de
questions en ce qui concernait ses
affaires comment est-ce que vous vous
appréhendez les prochaines semaines en
tant que président de l'Assemblée lors
des questions au gouvernement
pourra-t-il prendre la parole sur des
questions des députés en ce qui concerne
la justice et ce que ça encore ça ne va
pas entraîner un brouha une incapacité
pour le ministre de la Justice d'avoir
une parole libre dans les merci sur la
première question la sanction à Madame
obono n'est pas une sanction le reflet
d'un comportement collectif moi j'ai
sanctionné un comportement individuel
d'une députée qui malgré mes demandes ne
se taisait pas ne reprenez pas son calme
ne le retrouvez pas et continuait de
façon continue à invectiver
la ministre le député puis moi-même et
que malgré mes demandes de calme elle
n'y a pas souscrit c'est ça que je
sanctionne c'est l'invective à la
présidence nous avons des règles
communes à l'Assemblée nationale ce qui
est important de comprendre c'est que
nous sommes c'est le lieu du débat
démocratique organisé nous sommes tous
légitimes pour débattre nous avons tous
été élu par les citoyens français et
nous avons ensuite des règles des règles
qui font que notre débat
répond à
un ordre à une à un mode d'emploi il y a
un mode d'emploi du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'il faut suivre et dans ce
mode d'emploi il y a le respect que l'on
doit aux uns aux autres et au-delà tout
à la présidence de séance et donc c'est
ça qui n'est important de rappeler on ne
fait pas tout et n'importe quoi à
l'Assemblée nationale sous prétexte
qu'on a été élu on a des règles on a un
règlement il faut l'appliquer et c'est
finalement une de mes premières missions
de faire appliquer ce règlement et
j'invite chaque député à respecter ce
règlement c'est notre règle de vie
commune et c'est important et c'est
important de le rappeler
concernant le ministre de la Justice moi
en tant que président de l'Assemblée
nationale vous penserez bien que je ne
vais ni commenter les décisions de
justice qui sont qui sont prises ni la
réponse qui apporte l'exécutif chacun
est dans son rôle et le mien n'est
certainement pas de me dresser en
commentateur de cette actualité là donc
moi concernant d'une façon plus générale
les les futurs débats j'attends de tous
que il soit respectueux des uns et des
autres qu'ils soient apaisés après c'est
l'Assemblée nationale et c'est normal
que les uns et les autres expriment des
opinions politiques que ce soit Aurore
berger ou d'autres c'est le lieu pour se
faire
François Gervais le blog horizon
politique le groupe communiste a indiqué
hier qu'il comptait déposer une motion
référendaire pour qui pourraient être
voté par 58 membres
du de l'Assemblée nationale et qui si
cela avait été accepté aussi par le
Sénat d'une manière équivalente à vous
tirait à contraindre un référendum
notamment sur la réforme des retraites
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
connaissez cette objet
ne l'identifié pour l'instant de motion
référendaire je n'ai pas encore vu ce
que le groupe communiste voulait faire
dans le détail donc je pense en tout cas
que cette mandature sera l'objet de
toutes les innovations mais je trouve
que c'est intéressant en fait nous avons
des outils il faut s'en servir il faut
peut-être les redécouvrir pour faire en
sorte que le débat puisse vivre donc je
regarderai ça en tout cas avec avec
attention
plus globalement comment est-ce que vous
voyez l'articulation on parle beaucoup
de démocratie participative démocratie
sociale avec la concertation sur les
retraites comment est-ce que vous voyez
l'articulation entre ces différentes
formes de démocratie
et puis évidemment la démocratie
représentative avec le Parlement est-ce
qu'une meilleure articulation est
possible sans renier sur le rôle du
Parlement qui reste la pierre angulaire
de nos institutions en matière de
législation je suis extrêmement
favorable à la démocratie
participative moi je crois beaucoup au
fait que nos concitoyens veulent
s'investir dans le débat public en
dehors des simples temps électoraux où
ils élisent leur représentants ils
veulent pouvoir s'exprimer directement
en témoignent le succès du grand débat
en témoigne le succès modeste mais
existant des réunions publiques que l'on
fait en cours de mandat de la convention
citoyenne etc moi je crois qu'il faut
faire davantage participer nos
concitoyens mais qu'il faut le faire
dans la clarté et qu'en fait l'enjeu de
la démocratie participative c'est de
bien la combiner avec la démocratie
représentative de telle sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de confusion entre la mission
des uns et des autres les citoyens
peuvent être amenés à se prononcer et à
dire s'ils veulent oui ou non
telle ou tel action et c'est le
référendum qu'il soit local ou national
et là ils sont décisionnaires en tant
que peuple après il y a la participation
qui est on vous demande votre avis mais
vous n'êtes pas décisionnaire vous
débattez vous proposez vous proposer
vous suggérez mais la décision est
ailleurs et c'est le cas des conventions
citoyennes c'est le cas des grands
débats c'est le cas des réunions
publiques ont vous écoute on prend en
considération ce que vous dites mais
vous ne décidez pas et c'est
pas pouvoir exécutif quand il s'agit de
faire des prendre des décisions sur le
plan réglementaire soit le pouvoir
législatif quand il s'agit de prendre
des décisions par la loi et je pense que
une fois que ça c'est posé et clair il
faut absolument
encourager toutes les initiatives et
toutes les innovations moi je me suis
encore entretenue très récemment avec le
président du CESU Thierry baudet à
propos de la convention citoyenne sur la
sur la fin de vie et nous avons nous
avons convenu
de de justement d'avoir un temps
d'échange ensemble devant les citoyens
de la convention citoyenne pour
justement leur expliquer cela avoir ce
ce débat là avec eux pour que au début
de la convention citoyenne sur la fin de
vie nous n'ayons pas de malentendus et
que chacun comprenne bien quel est le
rôle et quel est son rôle qu'elle est sa
place je pense que c'est c'est
particulièrement sain de bien poser les
choses et de dire que cette réflexion
citoyenne elle est précieuse et qu'elle
peut avoir diverses formes qui
entraînent diverses conséquences
je crois Kevin une question au fond de
la salle ici merci Ludovic Nicolas
Prissette fondamental.fr je voudrais
revenir sur deux choses d'abord sur le
49-3 pour être bien sûr de vous avoir
compris est-ce que vous souhaitez que le
texte qui passerait au 49-3 soit la
version en débat dans l'hémicycle ou
bien la version du gouvernement c'est la
version qui leur a lui-même choisi ou
bien celle qui aura été amendée
éventuellement dans la discussion et
puis deuxième question je vais revenir
sur la CGR alors évidemment vous
répondez pas et c'est normal au sujet du
ministre de la justice mais sur cette
juridiction et son fonctionnement
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez il y a donc
on le sait 12 parlementaires qui siègent
ça veut dire que éventuellement le
ministre de la justice pourrait être
jugé par une majorité de parlementaires
qui lui sont politiquement opposés
est-ce que ce fonctionnement vous semble
normal est-ce que vous êtes favorable
comme il était Emmanuel Macron il y a
quelques temps à une réforme de cette
cour et
on transfert à la de ses compétences à
la cour d'appel est-ce que ça fait
partie aussi de des sujets
institutionnels sur lesquels vous
engagez merci
sur le sur le 49.3 je pense moi je suis
plutôt sur une position intermédiaire
en fait je pense que
non mais il faut je moi ce que je
souhaite et ce que je c'est que le texte
si encore une fois il fait l'objet d'un
49-3 qu'il tienne compte des débats dans
l'hémicycle ça ne veut pas dire que
le texte doit être exactement à la
virgule près le texte qui a été examiné
dans l'hémicycle sachant après qu'on je
ne sais pas jusqu'à quel point nous
pourrons aller dans l'hémicycle si nous
décidons et si le gouvernement décide de
l'utiliser en revanche il m'apparaît
qu'il ne faut pas non plus que ce soit
juste la copie du gouvernement il faut
tenir compte des différentes phases de
dialogue à nouveau et les phases de
dialogue comme je vous l'indiquais elles
ont il y a déjà eu au moins deux phases
de dialogue avec ces dialogues de Bercy
et avec la commission donc il faut tenir
il faudra à mon sens tenir compte de
tout cela si nous déclenchons si
gouvernement déclenche le 49-3 sur la
CGR moi j'ai toujours une position très
claire je suis favorable à la
suppression de la CGR
j'ai fait partie de la commission sauvée
des états généraux de la justice nous
avions un comité dans lequel j'étais
avec mon homologue du Sénat François
Noel buffet pour la commission des Lois
du Sénat nous étions une petite dizaine
et nous avons préconisé à l'unanimité la
suppression pure et simple de la CGR et
donc c'est à l'unanimité évidemment je
faisais partie de cette unanimité là
donc suppression de la CGR est-ce que
nous préconisions pour avoir un système
qui soit cohérent c'était non pas comme
en 2018 un renvoi à la cour d'appel de
Paris spécialement composé c'était ce
que nous avions inscrit dans le projet
de réforme constitutionnelle en 2018 il
nous a semblé qu'il fallait conserver un
double degré de Jurid puisque une des
critiques de la CGR c'est l'absence de
double degré du juridiction donc nous
voulions un double degré de juridiction
d'une part et notamment c'est pas
technique mais l'intérêt de supprimer la
CGR c'est aussi de pouvoir permettre à
ce que les poursuites puissent cesser
d'être disjointe aujourd'hui vous avez
les responsables politiques qui sont
jugés devant la CGR les complices les
co-auteurs non politiques sont jugés
devant des juridictions de droit commun
ce qui nous amène à des disjonctions
assez
néfaste de poursuite et une inégalité
puisque devant les juridictions de
droits communs on a première instance
appel alors que devant la CGR nous
n'avons pas de double degré juridiction
donc ce qui nous semblait intéressant et
c'est ce que nous avons préconisé avec
Jean-Marc Sauvé c'était de venir devant
le tribunal de Paris
tribunal judiciaire de Paris Première
Instance cour d'appel de Paris deuxième
instance comme ça nous revenons à une
des poursuites conjointes et un double
degré de juridiction
oui bonjour Pierre Ducan de contexte je
reviens vous avez évoqué les dialogues
de Bercy à l'instant cet été vous aviez
envoyé un courrier pour faire des
propositions pour améliorer le rapport
entre le pouvoir législatif et
l'exécutif et notamment la profession de
créer des groupes de contact avec des
représentants de chaque groupe avant
l'examen de chaque texte donc est-ce que
le dialogues de Bercy pour vous c'est
une piste
une bonne piste est-ce que vous
considérez que ce travail il a été fait
sur les autres textes les autres projets
de loi est-ce que quel regard quel
jugement
vous portez sur sur cette période parce
que sans session extraordinaire ça c'est
ma première question ma deuxième
question c'est qu'il y a eu des
propositions de certains groupes
notamment pour repenser le l'examen des
niches parlementaires soulignant que Ben
étant donné qu'il y a plus de groupes
mais il y a moins de il y a moins de
niche parlementaires pour chaque groupe
et donc le enfin en tout cas
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
d'examens de proposition de loi dans le
cadre de la Semaine réservé à
l'Assemblée est-ce que vous avez quel
est votre position là-dessus
alors sur la
les la nouvelle méthode qui que j'ai qui
était effectivement matérialisées par un
échange avec la première ministre cet
été
moi je crois que nous sommes réellement
sur la bonne voie réellement sur la
bonne voie parce que dans cette nouvelle
méthode c'est plus de concertation plus
de temps des textes plus courts plus
ramassés et
des ministres qui viennent présenter
notamment leurs feuilles de route devant
le Parlement et c'est ce à quoi nous
assistons vous avez et j'avais cité les
dialogues de Bercy je sais que la
ministre de l'Énergie Agnès panière une
hachée entamé des discussions pour
préparer son projet de loi ENR plus de
20 ministres ont été auditionnés devant
les commissions permanentes au mois de
septembre plus de 20 ministres pour
exposer leurs feuilles leurs feuilles de
route donc ce
cette concertation ces textes courts
sont en place et me semble être de bonne
augure pour la suite et montre que
réellement le Parlement et le
gouvernement sont en symbiose sur cette
façon de travailler nous irons
probablement plus loin avec la
participation de tous les groupes
politiques nous avons entamé ce travail
pour voir quels sont les nouvelles
méthodes que nous pouvons développer
améliorer pour pouvoir optimiser encore
ce fonctionnement là donc moi j'en suis
assez satisfaite et je continue à
travailler de ce sens là je pense que
c'est vraiment de bonne augure
concernant les les niches parlementaires
il y en a pas moins que avant pendant la
précédente mandature chaque groupe
politique avait une journée de niche par
session ordinaire et c'est ainsi que
nous allons poursuivre la question qui
se pose je sais celle de l'utilisation
des semaines de l'as dit de l'Assemblée
pour lesquels moi et c'est une
préconisation que j'avais faite dans mon
rapport sur un parlement renforcé que
j'avais écrit pour la Fondation Jean
Jaurès je préconisais qu'une partie de
ces semaines de l'Assemblée soit
utilisée pour examiner des propositions
de loi qui seraient issues de travaux
parlementaires transpartisans donc
issu de travaux de commission donc moi
je vais effectivement proposer aux
autres groupes politiques d'aller dans
cette direction et donc il faudra que
que l'on voit comment nous sélectionnons
ces textes là mais en tout cas trouver
des débouchés sur les semaines de
l'Assemblée à des textes qui sont
issus de travaux parlementaires de
mission parlementaire qui sont vraiment
la le travail parlementaire de fonds
transpartisans qui prend le au fond des
choses sur des choses qui sont pas
forcément très politiques mais qui
peuvent être extrêmement utiles aux
Français je prends toujours un exemple
d'une d'une proposition de loi qui avait
été rédigée en commission des lois par
Philippe Gosselin pour le groupe LR et
Laurence vichnieski pour le groupe modem
sur les actions de groupe on sait que
c'est des actions qui marchent pas très
bien en France ils avaient proposé une
PPL pour déverrouiller un certain nombre
de choses cette PPL elle est rédigée
elle est prête elle est dans les tiroirs
de l'Assemblée nationale il y en a comme
cela des dizaines est-ce que nous ne
pourrions pas utiliser ces semaines de
l'Assemblée pour pouvoir d'un commun
accord et là il faut vraiment qu'il y
ait une discussion avec toute la
Conférence des Présidents et l'ensemble
des groupes politiques pour savoir
qu'est-ce que s'il y a des propositions
de loi
issus de travaux parlementaires qui
méritent d'être inscrite et qui ont une
utilité et un sens aujourd'hui après il
y a également le travail à faire
conjointement avec le Sénat parce que
nous savons que nos textes on pourrait
exister pour devenir loi ont besoin
d'une navette parlementaire et donc là
il y a un dialogue à
entamer avec mon homologue et avec donc
entre les deux conférences des
présidents pour voir s'il y a des textes
qui pourraient faire l'objet d'une
navette à la main du Parlement d'accord
je pense que là il y a vraiment quelque
chose à faire pour vraiment rehausser le
travail du Parlement et permettre
l'adoption de texte qui sont trans
partisans et qui donc nous permettrait
de montrer aussi et d'incarner une
nouvelle façon une nouvelle façon de
faire il nous reste environ un quart
d'heure essayer de poser des questions
assez courtes pour qu'on en prenne un
maximum au fond de la salle à gauche
bonjour Jacques Macé journaliste nos
rêves vous aviez pris attache cet été
avec la présidente du groupe RN de
l'Assemblée notamment pour évoquer la
question de la la participation de
députés RN dans un certain nombre de
structures parlementaires d'organismes
parlementaires ou extraite parlementaire
s'agissait-il à cette occasion
simplement de parler du principe de la
représentation d'une certaine manière à
la proportionnelle dans ces organismes
ou avez-vous obtenu des garanties quant
à la participation des députés RN dans
ces structures
en fait je ne vois pas quel à quelle
entretien vous vous faites allusion moi
j'ai rencontré chacun chaque président
de groupe de l'Assemblée donc évidemment
Marine Le Pen en tant que président du
groupe rassemblement national mais nous
n'avons pas particulièrement évoqué les
organismes extra parlementaires nous
avons évoqué
l'ensemble pardon
vous pensez mais dites nous à quoi vous
pensez en fait
donc fallait le dire directement c'est
plus simple
la DPR en fait alors je vais je suis
désolé je vais pas être très courte mais
je vais essayer de pas être trop longue
la DR est un organisme que je connais
très bien j'en ai été membre pendant 5
ans et je l'ai présidé c'est la D il
s'agit de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement qui est un des seuls
organismes bicaméral qui est composé de
quatre députés et de quatre sénateurs et
la loi nous fait l'obligation d'avoir
une représentation au sein de cette
délégation qui correspondent à la
coloration politique du Parlement et
donc nous avons des des nominations à
faire au sein de cette délégation et il
y a également des membres de droit il y
a quatre membres de droits et quatre
membres à nommés deux par le Sénat et
deux par l'Assemblée nationale et donc
les dans les deux nominations que je
devais faire je devais tenir compte de
ces équilibres politiques et la
délégation la délégation parlementaire
ou l'enseignement est composé donc de
trois membres LR au Sénat et d'un membre
PS et à l'Assemblée nationale donc
statutairement de deux membres
renaissances donc en fait il y avait
pour correspondre à la couleur politique
de notre Parlement il manquait un membre
de la majorité donc j'ai procédé à la
nomination de Constance le grip femme et
membre de la majorité et il n'y avait
pas au sein de cette DPR le premier
groupe d'opposition à l'Assemblée
nationale qui se trouve être le
rassemblement national donc en fait si
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
que je suis
voulait mais je n'ai pas à vouloir
respecter la loi je dois la respecter
pour respecter la loi il fallait
désigner un membre rassemblement
national autrement je n'aurais pas
respecté la loi j'étais un peu longue
mais je pense qu'il faut être clair sur
ce sujet c'est le strict respect d'une
obligation légale
bonjour allez c'est la fontaine pour
Europe 1 certaines oppositions ont remis
en cause votre impartialité dans votre
Président je pense surtout au temps de
parole on entend du Mathilde panneau il
y a deux jours sur les temps de parole
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez
je pense que c'est c'est
anecdotique moi ce que j'entends des
oppositions et des présidents de groupe
c'est que il s'allume l'impartialité
avec lequel je conduis cette assemblée
depuis trois mois
oui bonjour Frédéric Delpech juste une
question sur votre la conception de
votre fonction parce qu'on a été très
surpris de votre prise de position sur
les retraites sur le un éventuel
amendement au PLFSS qui avait pour
lequel avait plaidé le président de la
République quelques jours plus tôt
devant des journalistes donc est-ce que
vous êtes un contre-pouvoir Emmanuel
Macron et au gouvernement et puis
question annexe sur la réforme des
retraites est-ce que vous souhaitez un
texte plein et entier ou éventuellement
un PLFSS rectificatif au début de
l'année
alors je ne sais pas pourquoi vous avez
été surpris parce que
c'était la seule position
institutionnelle en tant que président
de l'Assemblée nationale que je pouvais
avoir je considère et on vient d'en
parler depuis une heure je parle de
dialogue je parle de concertation je
parle de prendre le temps et donc cela
doit exister autant que faire se peut
sur l'ensemble des sujets que nous
abordons et je suis heureuse que sur la
question des retraites nous puissions
avec le gouvernement puisse mettre en
place une méthode qui permet de
satisfaire à l'exigence de cette
concertation et de ce dialogue et en
même temps à l'exigence de la réforme
que nous devons conduire donc moi je
suis
très satisfait de cette situation le
texte pourra venir rapidement et donc
être en oeuvre avant l'été 2023 et dans
des conditions qui me paraîtrent me
paraissent respecter le temps du débat
après qu'il s'agisse d'un texte dédié ou
d'un
plfssr franchement ça c'est c'est de la
technique ce qui est important pour moi
c'est ce temps ce dialogue et c'est
surtout et c'est surtout d'aboutir à
faire cette réforme qui est nécessaire
mais de faire une réforme complète et
équilibrée et c'est la voix qui a choisi
de d'emprunter le gouvernement et je ne
peux que m'en satisfaire et mon
féliciter
bonjour Hélène pilichowski journaliste
honoraire bon vous êtes la première vous
êtes la première femme élue présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale en France vous
semblez très à l'aise dans la fonction
et on ne peut que s'en féliciter
avez-vous depuis que vous êtes à votre
tâche avez-vous ressenti parfois une
certaine agressivité qu'aurait été
plutôt destinée aux femmes plutôt qu'aux
hommes est-ce que vous est-ce que vous
sentez que vous êtes désormais reconnu
admise et que tout se passe bien pour
vous et que ça va continuer comme ça
parce que nous on s'étonne un peu puis
je voudrais savoir si vous partagez des
positions d'Elisabeth bad faire en ce
qui concerne la dérive actuelle des
problèmes féministes sur la société
devant la société en privé en dehors de
la justice du pays
non moi je en fait je suis très
surprises depuis que j'ai été élu
des réactions des citoyens
en fait j'ai beaucoup de femmes mais
beaucoup d'hommes aussi qui viennent me
féliciter et qui sont fiers que la
France est élu une première femme
présidente de l'Assemblée et ce que je
trouve très touchant c'est papa qui me
présente leur fille leur petite fille et
l'autre jour j'étais au marché pour tout
vous dire et j'ai un papa qui est venu
vers moi avec une petite fille de 3 ans
et demi et en lui disant tu vois c'est
la dame dont je t'ai parlé et il était
fier de me la présenter et je trouve que
ça c'est très touchant et je n'avais pas
mesuré que à quel point dans l'opinion
publique le fait que il y ait une
première femme sa porte et de façon
extrêmement positive encourageante et
voilà donc je sens cet élan et je vous
dis je peux vous dire que c'est très
réjouissant parce que c'est très porteur
c'est très porteur et ça vous fait
prendre conscience de du fait qu'il
s'est passé quelque chose à l'Assemblée
nationale et
et voilà c'est très émouvant en fait
c'est très émouvant
après sur les sur les les positions des
uns et des autres moi je suis sur une un
féminisme
de de
positif et non conflictuel moi je
n'oppose jamais les hommes et les femmes
quand on parle de féminisme bien au
contraire bien au contraire je n'aurais
jamais été élu si des hommes n'avaient
pas voté pour moi non mais c'est évident
en fait ce qui paraît évident doit être
dit on n'est pas le combat du féminisme
n'est pas j'allais dire ça doit plus
être un combat et moi je trouve
franchement
que l'assemblée aujourd'hui
n'est plus un lieu sexiste n'est plus un
lieu
[Musique]
où ce combat doit être mené je trouve
quand même qu'il faut regarder le
paysage de l'Assemblée on a une femme
présidente j'ai si vice-président sur
mes 6 vice-présidents j'ai 5 femmes
vice-présidentes de séance pour la
première fois de l'histoire de
l'Assemblée notre première questeur est
une femme
on peut pas dire que les choses n'ont
pas bougé que les choses n'ont pas
changé il faut s'en satisfaire et il
faut aussi reconnaître et je crois que
c'est quand même un élément majeur dire
que l'on a franchi des étapes et qu'on
les franchit et que on doit se
satisfaire que aujourd'hui l'assemblée
de 2022 n'est pas celle de 1981 ou celle
voilà il se passe des choses c'est un
long mouvement c'est un long combat
c'est un c'est un long chemin sur lequel
et bien on a pu compter à chaque fois
fois sur les hommes et moi je suis dans
cette logique là
20 minutes vous avez dit que c'était une
opportunité c'est la nouvelle
composition de l'Assemblée pour
reconnecter avec les Français du coup
est-ce que la menace d'une dissolution
c'est un risque ou est-ce que comme le
49-3 c'est pas un gros mot c'est pas un
gros mot comme le 49-3 comme la motion
de censure comme le mot voilà ce sont
des mots de notre Constitution ils
participent d'un équilibre global et je
crois qu'il faut il faut que chacun est
nécessaire est utile chacun est
nécessaire est utile maintenant moi je
pense que
finalement si le président devait
décider d'une dissolution cela
signifierait que notre assemblée est
dans l'incapacité de remplir sa mission
et qu'elle est dans l'incapacité de
débattre et de voter des textes qui qui
souhaitent utile et effectivement si
nous en arrivions à cette situation de
blocage total de l'institution et bien
je le considère que ce serait notre
échec à nous notre échec nous au 577
parlementaires si nous ne sommes pas
capables de faire en sorte que cette
assemblée fonctionne et bien ce serait
notre faute c'est notre responsabilité
et donc voilà moi je en tout cas je mets
aujourd'hui tout en heure pour qu'elles
fonctionnent et c'est le cas elle
fonctionne depuis le mois le mois de
juin encore hier nous avons terminé les
débats sur le texte relatif à
l'assurance chômage dans les temps nous
ferons le vote mardi prochain donc voilà
nous avons une institution qui
fonctionne mais et c'est ma mission mais
je ne suis pas seule à devoir l'assumer
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe et
l'ensemble au-delà l'ensemble des
parlementaires nous sommes responsables
de cela et je pense sincèrement que nous
en sommes même comptables aux yeux des
Français
une dernière question dans le rapport
que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure que
vous allez rédiger en fin de législature
précédente sur la revalorisation du rôle
du Parlement sur un ordre du jour et un
temps mieux maîtrisé par le Parlement
vous faisiez un certain nombre de
propositions est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
considérez que le dialogue avec le
gouvernement est suffisant ou est-ce
qu'un certain de réformes du Règlement
de l'Assemblée nationale pourrait être
nécessaire en cours de en cours de
législature
pour le moment moi comme je le disais
tout à l'heure j'ai je suis très
satisfaite de la façon dont cette
législature commence et dans ce dialogue
renouvelé entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement donc nous allons
continuer avec cette méthode là nous
pouvons amplifier cette méthode sans
avoir besoin de changer ni le règlement
et ni la Constitution et c'est le sens
de des travaux que j'ai entamé avec
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe
jusqu'où pouvons-nous aller dans cette
nouvelle méthode à ISO règlement
isoconstitution cela ne nous interdit
pas néanmoins dans la réflexion plus
globale sur les institutions dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure d'y inclure les
sujets de rapport entre le Parlement et
le gouvernement finalement aussi du
fonctionnement même du Parlement nous
avions parce qu'il y a des sujets qui
peuvent être constitutionnels et en
rapport avec notre fonctionnement
interne et donc tout cela doit
travailler dans un cadre plus global
pour le moment moi ce que je souhaite
c'est vraiment et c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui m'obsède c'est finalement comment
réussir à impulser les changements assez
rapidement et donc tout ce qui passe par
une réforme réglementaire législative
vous constitutionnelle nous emmène déjà
un peu plus loin en temporalité donc le
travail que nous effectuons de façon
collégiale c'est plutôt un travail sur
la méthode et sur la pratique plutôt que
de changement de la règle
voilà une heure c'est à la fois beaucoup
et peu il est presque midi l'heure déjà
de nous quitter merci madame la
Présidente d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'espère on espère que vous
reviendrez prochainement bonne journée à
tous ici et sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]